[Musique]
après tout un mois de réflexion portait
sur la santé des aidants c'est dans
l'hémicycle du département que les
professionnels de santé clôture cette
action à la réunion ils sont 46 milles
et donc des proches à s'occuper d'une
personne dépendante handicapés aux
malades
le département accompagne ces aidants au
travers de dispositifs visant à les
former et à soulager la fatigue physique
et psychologique à laquelle ils doivent
faire face nous avons mis en place des
mesures qui n'existent pas parfois sur
le plan national
je pense aux résidences répit repos je
pense à la maison des accueillants
familiaux et bien toutes ces mesures
sont là pour accompagner les aidants
votre rôle est essentiel mais il faut
aussi penser à vous c'est ce que nous
nous efforçons de faire compagne et les
aidants nécessite effectivement ben
l'accompagnement fait par des
professionnels donc des assistants
sociaux et des psychologues des
infirmiers et des actions que l'on mène
des actions collectives que l'on mène
sur les territoires donc ce qui
manquerait c'est pas forcément
aujourd'hui les actions existent des
actions existent mais beaucoup plus de
communication
il était important d'insister sur la
place de l'aidant qui reste un proche et
qui ne doit pas se substituer au rôle du
professionnel des aidants qui s'oublie
bien souvent et qui ne doivent pas
perdre le lien avec la société
un aidant sur trois se dit anxieux et
stressé pour la plupart ils se
sacrifient entièrement au profit de la
personne qu'ils aident et au point de
s'oublier en fait un et de se sacrifier
et c'est là qu'on en arrive justement
une chromatique d'épuisement de fatigue
qui engendre ces problématiques
psychopathologique dont se parler pour
nous pour toute l'équipe du gps taper
c'est important en fait qu'on qu'on
travaille à ce que c'est et dans l'aprem
si ce n'est qu'un tout petit peu de
temps aussi pour eux et pour leur
bien-être à eux pour pouvoir ensuite
davantage s'occuper des autres avoir
cette énergie là pour pourra s'occuper
de la personne qu'ils aident au
quotidien les différentes conférences
auront mené à des pistes de travail et
encore plus sur la nécessité pour les
professionnels d'accompagner les aidants
[Musique]